in we will conduct this press conference
in English thank you so much for being
here uh a little late because Ursula's
flight was a little bit delayed but we
are very happy to have her here for her
first time in Iceland visit and
hopefully not the last
um
um I will say just in the beginning that
we're extremely happy to have her here
and I'm also very happy that you're one
of the many leaders attending this very
important Summit at the Council of
Europe
uh starting this afternoon but we also
use the time to meet bilaterally and
talk about important issues concerning
the relation of Iceland and EU where we
have a long and good cooperation of
course Iceland has aligned fully with EU
on the sanctions against Russia because
of the war in Ukraine
we're on the same site in regard for
when it comes to accountability which
we're going to talk about at the summit
and of course we have had a very close
cooperation during the pandemic and I
will use this opportunity to thank you
again for that very good cooperation
so
um I don't think I need to have this
very long
uh we talked uh about the fact that the
great e agreement has we are celebrating
the 30th Anniversary next year and we
will use that opportunity to organize uh
some meetings and to talk about the
importance of this agreement
we have also changed talked about some
practical matters like the mission
trading system for Aviation as part of
the fit for 55 program and
I will say here that
I I am
positive that we will find a good
solution to that matter
uh the EU and Ursula have shown a great
understanding for our views and our
geographical situation uh so our common
view is that a solution to this should
take into account Iceland's specific
geographical situation
it's a good thing that she just flew her
prevents possible carbon leakage but
also address the fact that the Green
Solutions in aviation have not yet
emerged however I will also would also
like to make it completely clear that
Iceland built to contribute to the
common goal of reducing emissions and
and that is absolutely uh our common
understanding of this so thank you thank
you rasulullah and please the floor is
yours yeah thank you very much Kathleen
thank you for having me here
um and I want to congratulate you and
your country to the very successful
presidency of the Council of Europe I'm
very much looking forward to this Summit
it comes at a very relevant time we've
discussed it
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine raises fundamental questions
about democracy about the rule of law
about the human rights and I want to
particularly thank you for putting the
question of Justice
for Ukraine and the accountability of
Russia
at the heart of your presidency this is
very important I also want to thank you
and the people of Iceland for the
generosity and the support you are
constantly giving to Ukraine as far as I
know you welcomed almost 3 000 refugees
with open arms you donated vital
supplies and energy equipment you're
channeling important economic support to
Ukraine so many many thanks for that
we have an excellent bilateral
cooperation and I should talk now about
10 minutes about what is all going well
but we do not have the time for that
indeed uh turning to the bilateral
relations
um there are a few topics we went a bit
more in depth besides the excellent
cooperation that we have and the
seamless work that takes place between
our different respective teams
so of course the overriding topic the
first one is climate change and how to
fight climate change Iceland knows that
better than anyone we are both concerned
about the impact and convinced about the
need that we do have to act you have to
decided to do something about it with
your ambitious plan to be carbon neutral
by 2014.
and I am deeply impressed almost already
today almost 100 percent
of your electricity production in
Iceland comes from renewable you know
that we also have ambitious plans to
reach climate neutrality by 2050 and
there of course to develop Renewables as
much as possible
we want to reach more than 42 percent of
our energy consumption through
Renewables by 2030.
so we must address the emissions and
that's the reason why we have started
the emission trading system the mission
trading system is Market driven it's
very successful but of course we have to
take into account the specific situation
of Iceland and I think
um we have found a very good common
understanding
as you said subject to some fine tuning
still but in our case it is of course
that we have to have the approval of the
member state but I'm happy that we
really found a solution that is
compatible with your specific situation
it is compatible with our integrity our
common Integrity of the single market
and most importantly it is also
respecting the long-term goals of
climate protection
voila this is it basically
um there were smaller things we were
also discussing but I want to thank you
again for the excellent cooperation and
for the fact that you're an outstanding
presidency of the Council of Europe
thank you so much thank you so much and
now there is time for a few questions a
few questions not so many though no a
few short ones first enter smart person
from multiple newspaper is a Madam
president uh happy to hear that you made
such a progress on the emissions uh well
Aviation missions but how quickly do you
think you can formalize that
well I think we have to as I said
Our member states
um so the idea is
um that Iceland
um gets a offer to have free allowances
that Iceland can give in not only 25 but
also 26 2026
and it is important that it is possible
to give that to all Airlines so there is
a Level Playing Field it's a question of
um of fairness and
um therefore I think we have now to
consult our stakeholders with meets the
27 member states with you it's your
stakeholders you know better but we
basically found a solution that is
compatible and we need to obviously
discuss this within uh the Icelandic
government the Icelandic Parliament so
obviously there remains a lot of work
but we think we have at least a common
understanding of what needs to be done
to find the good solution to this
and now we have Humanity from the
Icelandic
um
[Music]
what do you see as expectations from the
Reykjavik Summit especially in the field
of the peace process for Ukraine
yes I think
um there the Reykjavik Summit comes
absolutely at the right time
first of all it will be a big topic will
be the accountability of Russia for the
crime of regression it is constantly
committing by Waging War in Ukraine here
I'm very glad that we will have the
register of Damages which is so
important for Justice and Justice is one
of the preconditions for just peace
but also over time also when we think in
terms of reconstruction so it's an
enormously important judicial element to
have this register of damages
to give Justice to the victims
what peace is concerned we have a very
clear position we support strongly the
peace formula of president zelenski that
he has put forward this I think is the
basis from which on we will be working
and this has then to be discussed but it
is very clear that we have a principle
nothing about Ukraine without Ukraine
um and therefore Ukraine as the victim
of the perpetrator Ukraine as the victim
has to be the one who puts out the basic
Foundation of a peace formula which
which we then can work president
zelenski I met him last week is very
open to discussion but important for all
of us is this is the basis from which on
we are working on
talking about
how we can actually proceed built on the
basis of the Ukrainian peace formula we
have the Ukrainian prime minister who
has just arrived here to Iceland so I am
hopeful that that discussion will
actually help us to proceed to adjust
peace but I must also agree with Ursula
peace cannot be without Justice
one last question Elizabeth from Channel
2 News Iceland thank you madam is the
European Union going to increase their
support to Ukraine
so we have of course we will stay and
support Ukraine for as long as it takes
um there are two types of support the
one is the financial support overall by
now we supported Ukraine with 68 billion
euros
if you look at the different elements of
support and then there is the military
support this is more a question of the
member states but there's a strong
commitment of this member states of
course also here to support Ukraine so
as we know that's the ukrainians are
fighting very bravely for their
sovereignty and the Integrity of their
territory they are fighting for
principles of the international law and
the U.N Charter and therefore they are
fighting also for us and it is for us
therefore a noble task to support
Ukraine for as long as it takes
okay so thank you so much and we'll meet
again thank you thank you
foreign